hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today I'm back with an
evidence-base how-to on detoxing spoiler
alert
there'll be no lemon juice cayenne
pepper or maple syrup concoctions gross
nobody wants to drink that [ __ ] then
just try my five easy ways to cleanse
and detox your body using every day
organs candy I don't need nothing
special for this you got it all going on
number one the kidney cleanse be sure to
diurese daily don't know what diurese
thing is well that's when your kidneys
remove toxins from the blood and let you
urinate them out so as long as you can
pee you're good to go number two
the lung cleanse breathe in oxygen
breathe out carbon dioxide have you ever
had to think about one through manually
hopefully not well let's do it together
now congratulations you just cleansed
here are some of my favorite breathing
techniques the dog you dog the pregnant
woman or everyone's favorite yoga
breathing technique the Lions breath get
real people just breathe
number three the skin cleanse dispel
excess moisture from your skin when you
get hot in other words guys sweat now I
know sweat circles are kind of
embarrassing and dry-cleaning bills on
silk shirts expensive but consider those
sweat stains a trophy
believe it or not guys your skin is one
of your largest cleansing organs so go
for a good run and let it do its job
number four the digestive cleanse I've
put into your gob let it move through
your body and poop it out
uh yes sir few things in life that guy
doesn't love more than the top but
seriously now your intestines job is to
remove nutrients from the food you eat
and get rid of the crap literally yes
you heard me pooping may seem dirty but
it's actually inherently cleansing and
if you really want to take your bathroom
cleansing sesh to the next level go get
yourself some more water and some fiber
rich fruits veggies and whole grains and
let er rip
and number five the liver cleanse Auto
engage in oxidation reduction hydrolysis
conjugation following exposure to any
food medication alcohol volatile
compound airplane or pretty much
anything else you can come into contact
with what no one's ever shown you how to
enter in the conjugation pathway and
piss out the toxins you ingest oh that's
okay cuz your liver does it for you all
the time when you pee your cleansing
yeah see you're doing a cleanse right
now do what you feel better already
I'm glad I saved you from another bogus
two and a dollar cleansing kit you're
welcome
well thanks so much for watching guys
we're great healthy eating tips and
tricks be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen a lot of people ask me
how I managed to get everything done the
day I like to think it's cuz I'm a woman
obviously but it also has a lot to do
with caffeine I do love myself a good
cup of coffee or tea but there are
definitely more helpful ways to get in
your fix than others case in point the
Frappuccino full fat milk sickly sweet
syrups candy bits and mountains of
whipped cream make these calorie bombs
more of a decadent dessert than a
refreshing summer drink